always Keen to stress their Unity NATO
members gathered during the second year
of a war in Europe This Time those small
cracks are showing which Alliance
leaders are working hard to overcome
Central to this meeting is the question
of Ukraine's possible future membership
promised at some point with some allies
pushing for a fast-track process to
begin Now While others notably Germany
and the United States believe the time
is not yet right we reaffirmed that
Ukraine will become a member of NATO
and agreed to remove the requirement for
a membership action plan
this will change Ukraine's membership
path
from a two-step process to a one-step
process
we also made clear that we will issue an
invitation for Ukraine to join NATO when
allies agree and conditions are met but
that falls well short of Ukrainian
expectations
got a hero's welcome in Vilnius but on
Route he tweeted that anything less than
a firm invitation now and a timetable
for accession would be absurd amounting
to uncertainty he said that Russia would
view as weakness
is the language of hesitation and Putin
understands only the language of force
so that's something which our allies
should understand but it is not a
catastrophe there is the word invitation
Ukraine will skip membership action plan
stage many especially members of the
alliance's Eastern flank would tend to
agree with Ukraine While others
including Germany and the United States
believe that with the war still on and
no way of knowing what any possible
peace agreement might look like now is
simply not the time to commit the whole
of NATO to Ukraine's defense against
future Russian aggression there are
other points of tension unease over the
supply of cluster Munitions to Ukraine
by the United States most NATO members
are signatories to a treaty Banning
their use but not Ukraine the U.S or
Russia
and among pledges of further Military
Support came The Promise by France to
follow the UK in supplying long-range
missiles to Ukraine
one potential difficulty was overcome on
the eve of the summit when Turkish
president
erdogan lifted his year-long objection
to formally neutral Sweden joining the
alliance 31 members will soon become 32
NATO expanding because of the war in
Ukraine even as the war exerts pressures
that test its Unity Jonah Al Jazeera
Vilnius
and Russia says NATO expansion on its
borders is a mistake and that Ukraine is
being manipulated by the alliance to
advance its agenda against Moscow Al
Jazeera spoke exclusively to Maria
zakarova who's a spokeswoman for the
Russian foreign Ministry she says NATO
doesn't want Ukraine as a member of the
military Alliance
what support for Ukraine you can see
here because NATO decides not to include
Ukraine what support are we talking
about so it seems that Ukraine and NATO
members have been calling Ukraine to in
the into the Western World at the time
when Ukraine calls for help they
abandoned the Ukraine they let Ukraine
down you should see the reality instead
of making up stories and rather than
repeating the statements of Secretary
General stoltenberg and if we think
about the question why Ukraine is not
included in nature ranks it is quite
interesting they invite Finland
and Sweden but not Ukraine why this is a
question that should be posted all TV
channels why not because you see
multi-billion financial aid is provided
to Ukraine through NATO it doesn't
matter if countries are doing that
together or individually
they're providing arms to Ukraine so why
not Ukraine is not a member of NATO